yeah Minnie to his place take down the
man Freddie mom we've all been let's
Ironman well not too busy doing your job
oh I'm kidding I'm kidding look keep up
the good work because I am going on
vacation
how's darks
what's up we're just talking about the
trip
[Music]
who is that guy he's like Iron Man so we
rolled into one
what are you gonna do nothing new guys
all over it
your new fury put some clothes on let's
go for a ride
this is mr. Beck we have a job to do
you're coming with me fury just hijacked
our summer vacation I didn't think I was
gonna have to save the world the Sun but
you won't Peter I want to go back on my
trip the girl I really like and tell her
how I feel
MJ I'm spider-man no of course I mean
it's kind of obvious
let's go save the world
you take care of the suit I'll take care
of the music
I'm gonna get so many followers
oh yeah never never doing that again I'm
never doing that again
[Music]
the costume was great she knows I told
her hey didn't tell me I figured it out
it's cool I mean I've known first and
I'm gonna longer but it's not a
competition cool yeah cool how's it
going everybody it's Laurent and in an
interesting turn of events we have a
leaked Spiderman far from home trailer
it's unclear where this came from or how
it got out but there is a lot of new
footage in it so let's go and break it
down quick reminder about my giveaway
when I hit 450,000 subscribers I will be
picking three winners to pick one item
from the Marvel Legends series
collection so be sure to subscribe to my
channel so you can enter so this trailer
starts off with something very important
Peter is talking to Aunt May and she
asks him if he took down the Manfredi
mob this is an Easter Egg and a
reference to a spider-man villain
Silvermane who also goes by the name
Silvio Manfredi Silvermane runs a
criminal organization that is basically
a mob so this is the mob that she is
referring to and in the comics
Silvermane works with many villains
including Hydra and kingpin so it'll be
interesting to see if this means
something in spider-man far from home or
if it's just a little Easter Egg after
the scene we have the normal talk of
Peter going on vacation and then we have
this scene with hydro-man we have a
little bit of new footage here including
how Hydra man arrives and when he
arrives Ned and Betty are in a canal
boat together and Hydra man caused us so
much commotion in the water that he
actually manages to splash them onto the
shore this is just one instance of
probably the many times that Peter
Parker's friends are going to be in
trouble in Spider Man far from home and
we know this because we've heard Peters
say in other trailers that he wants to
protect his friends and we also know
that some of his friends at least are
going to figure out that he is Spider
Man which also puts them in jeopardy
the Mysterio shows up and he helps fight
Hydra man and then we get some footage
that we haven't seen before a
conversation between Ned and Peter
Parker
Ned asked Peter what are you going to do
and Peter says nothing that new guys all
over it
so we know by now from many trailers
that Peter is just trying to enjoy a
vacation as a teenager he doesn't really
want to be spider-man right now he's
mourning the loss of Tony Stark's still
as well this is something that actually
happens quite
often spider-man tries to not become
spider-man anymore but just beat Peter
Parker but then of course something
happens where he has to come back a
spider-man and we actually get more of
him talking about just enjoying his
vacation as a teenager in the next news
scene that we get in this trailer we see
spider-man in his stealth suit and he's
fighting molten man alongside of
Mysterio now it's unclear if they have
actually met at this point but they
probably have considering their first
interaction is most likely with
hydro-man so this is possibly the first
footage that we got of them working
together to take on an elemental not
Mysterio stepping in at the last minute
to help save Peter Parker and during
this footage that is being shown we hear
Peter say I didn't think that I was
going to have to save the world this
summer again referring to the fact that
he doesn't really want to be spider-man
at this point in time he just wants to
be a normal teenager and enjoy his
vacation he's also trying to tell MJ
that he likes her and trying to start a
relationship with her and also trying to
mourn the loss of Tony Stark's though
which is what he says when Mysterio asks
him what do you want Peter he says I
just want to go back on my trip with a
girl that I really like and tell her how
I feel so in this scene right here not
only do we find out that Peter just
really wants to be a teenager right now
but it's also Mysterio trying to be a
mentor to Peter Parker now this is part
of Mysterio's plan he does not want
Peter Parker to be spider-man this is
because Mysterio wants to be the main
hero he wants to be the next Iron Man so
he's trying to get Peter out of the way
so Mysterio's attempt to mentor Peter is
really him trying to get him to not be
spider-man anymore
that way when spider-man is gone
Mysterio can step in and be the hero
that everybody loves so this is going to
be Mysterio's first tactic he's going to
try and convince Peter to just be a
teenager and not be spider-man but of
course at some point in time in the
movie that will fail Peter will come
back a spider-man and the Mysterio will
have to try and defeat spider-man so we
can take his place then we have brief
footage of Mysterio telling Peter let's
go save the world and then we cut to a
scene with happy and Peter Peter is
unhappy super-advanced plain this is
either a stark industry plain or it's a
shield plane because the plane is super
advanced we hear happy tell Peter you
take care of the suit I'll take care of
the music so happy is obviously going to
play a very important role in the MCU
moving forward he was Tony's bright hand
man super close with him and pepper at
the end of Avengers
game we saw him taking care of little
Morgan stark and now he's being a mentor
to Peter and in this scene we see the
new spider-man suit the red and black
one being made we know that Peter is
going to fight some of the elementals at
first and have a really hard time
fighting them we've also seen in other
trailers spider-man suit kind of burned
when he goes in hugs MJ so his first
suit probably gets pretty much destroyed
fighting an elemental and now he has to
make a new suit so that's what we see in
this scene right here and then
immediately after we see the plane
flying away from smoke and fire
obviously this is one of the elementals
or a few of them Peter is on the wing of
the plane he has his new suit and we see
him jump off and go into the fight we
then have a scene of spider-man
web-slinging with MJ on his arm this
takes place in New York so this could
take place after the events of
spider-man far from home play out
because MJ would know that Peter Parker
is spider-man
so it's either at the end or in the very
beginning of the movie before they go on
their vacation but she talks to him like
she does know that it's Peter she says
okay I'm never doing that again so it's
almost like MJ and Peter are now
together after all the events happened
in spider-man far from home and Peter is
like hey do you want to go for a swing
to see what it's like but we'll see when
the movie comes out and then we have a
comedic scene at the end where MJ
discovers that Peter is spider-man he's
in his stealth suit and then Ned walks
in and says that the suit looks great
Peter then leaves and we see Ned get a
little bit jealous of Peters romantic
interest and he wants to make it known
that he is spider-man's best friend and
he knew about Peter first so that's it
for this new leaked spider-man far from
home trailer that we got I'm guessing
that this trailer will probably come out
pretty soon it could even come out today
but I wanted to get it to you all as
fast as I possibly could so let me know
what you think about it and let me know
what you think about these brand new
spider-man far from home scenes let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and again another reminder about
my giveaway when I hit 450,000
subscribers I will be picking three
winners and each winner will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection I'll also be doing a
big giveaway at the 500,000 subscriber
mark and I'll be doing some giveaways on
Instagram and Twitter if you want to
follow me on there as well if you'd like
to enter the giveaway for your chance to
win all you have to do is be subscribed
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero or villain
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
your head in Avengers and game a
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very Nass and
all it took
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby now your